hey guys it's Justine and happy holidays
I am super hyped because today we're
gonna do some crafting I absolutely love
doing holiday crafts I haven't done any
for a very long time though so I'm a
little nervous we've got a glue gun
we've got scissors we've got tape we've
got all kinds of things happening here
so the first thing that we're gonna do
is we're going to make a little
Christmas wreath but before we get into
that we do have a giveaway going on all
this week with all kinds of really cool
products check out ijustine.com vlogmas
for all of the details on how to enter
so the first thing we're going to do is
draw a six inch circle neither one of
these are six inches but we're just
gonna we're just gonna work with what
we've got
there we go and then we're going to do
one Center Circle
oh yeah
beautiful so now we need to cut 6
X6 pieces and four by six pieces
let's go I like lightsaber twirling
except
it's not a saber
six I'm just gonna cut a nice strip now
I'm using very precise measurements here
very well
there's a slight slant
here
okay one two three four five
okay I'm gonna try it more straight on
this one
here we go
look at this Precision look at this
accuracy have you seen anything
more accurate No this is like gonna be
my only Christmas decoration because I
didn't have time to decorate for
Christmas
um you know what I should be doing this
in other colors too they're gonna have
it all Silver Reef
mixing it up now
oh so if it's six by six six by six
would mean it was like
I think I've really done a very bad job
wow my measurement is so garbage this is
not even straight at all I have no idea
what I've done I have no idea how many
are here I don't know anything
so I'm gonna cut this out this is all
gonna be covered up anyway
so now we're gonna make little cones
foreign
I'm doing this to the best of my ability
okay double sick tape is Magic look at
this okay that's nice I'm gonna try to
do this a little bit better for my
second one
nice
oh okay the first one's really pathetic
but we'll just let it we'll let it slide
everyone starts somewhere
[Music]
this is gonna look so incredible I'm
gonna hang it on the door
[Music]
so I don't think that I have enough but
we're gonna work with what we've got
that's success in YouTube working with
what you've got this is this is what
we've got their wreath is very full it's
very full with beautiful wreath-like
qualities maybe this one's not gonna be
as full it's good it's gonna um we lost
the light over here but it now it looks
like a little light show oh well nice
the skinny and this
I'll start doing that over here okay
here we go
my phone shut off so I didn't I didn't
see what I was doing
this one doesn't even have an end
skinny end here
it's like a yeah things have really
escalated
okay that looks
um
but that's okay because we're not done
yet
that looks good okay great love that
okay so there's already looks
significantly better than mine we're
gonna glue these balls into the center
glue gun ready to go oh there we go
great look at that yes
yes
okay
[Music]
hey Laura I'm coming for your Channel
with lists look at this you see this
you're shaking I know
have you seen a more beautiful thing
[Music]
okay progress is being made
this should be up for auction like this
is going to be on art galleries
all around the world
a little garbage
[Music]
it's a masterpiece an absolute
masterpiece
I feel like I need one more okay one
more one more just to really bring this
to life I think that should go right
here
let me just step back just to give it
another set of eyes here not only a
different perspective okay I think I
need one more right there that's it this
is it this is the final the final
countdown
let's just get this all set in there let
that sit for a minute and we can do the
big reveal so this craft is actually
super cute it's a wine glass snow globe
let's see what happens first thing we
need to do we've already seen my tracing
skills which are impeccable we need to
trace around the wine class
nice okay
I'm gonna try to cut this out a little
better than I did for my wreath
I'm just gonna use this to protect the
island because I have a feeling that I'm
going to make a mess we need to put some
fake snow
into our snow globe
I have made a mess no
how much do you think we should put in
like more do you think more a little
less less more
oopsies oh it's all over the floor what
we've we have done some things okay I
think that's good because it's going to
be like that we've got some little trees
we're gonna put in here
oh these are so cute look at this oh my
goodness I think I'm gonna do like a
little green tree
and then we have a little figurine this
little guy which we're gonna Jam him in
there as well I think I'm gonna put him
this way
here he is he looks lovely I think I
just
do this we're gonna be ready to go
oh that's so hot oh gosh hot glue gun is
hot surprise it's running all the way
down the glass that can just be like a
little icicle feature the Precision the
skill all right oh gosh it's oh no no no
no little guy you stay you oh boy oh boy
[Music]
it's great everything is awesome I'm
gonna just seal it because I have a
feeling some of the snow is going to
leak out I'm gonna be very upset about
it
[Music]
okay but I want to flip it over and see
what it looks like ready
oh okay he's there we go okay the tree
has fallen down
these okay so okay so this is now
this is now turned into like one of
those like puzzle games okay
oh don't worry this is all gonna work
out great
Have Yourself a Merry Little Christmas
okay so maybe it's just gonna be a side
situation okay he's up he's upright now
the tree is upside down we're going
through some things so I think what
probably would have worked out better is
if we would have glued this to the paper
but my little dude was too big so I
couldn't actually fit him in there so
everything's fine this is beautiful I
think it's great moving on we now need
to put our candle on top so this is like
a little snow globe candle holder I do
imagine when you light this candle and
it melts it's going to get absolutely
everywhere so just don't say that this
was my idea like we literally Googled it
and found some inspo
nice look at that look at that
oh look at this this would look so yes
this will look nice right around here
it's probably gonna burn the wax but
it's fine everything is fine
so I think I'm just gonna
do one of these and wrap it
so it has melted through the wax
oh it's so hot oh geez I'm burning
I can't touch it because then I'll burn
my other fingers I'm gonna tie it
here we go
this looks nice
oh oh no oh oh yeah okay well we've got
some ribbon here so we can do a little
oh this will look good yeah like a
little wrap around here beautiful oh my
God my finger is burnt off
it's like hot glue gun is hot who would
have thought
oh my gosh this is so beautiful this is
incredible like Martha Stewart is
probably just shaking in herself as she
out of jail I think she's out she's been
out for a while right yeah she's out I
don't know I'll probably see her soon
this crime that I've committed here we
go have ourselves a Holly Jolly Chris
I'm shaking oh my God I'm shaking so bad
okay as my only source of decoration
second to the wreath that I've just
created I'm gonna have to go with maybe
it's questionable questionable this
looks like something that I would have
made like when I was in kindergarten
that I brought him to my mom and she'd
be like super stoked like wow that's so
nice that's beautiful it's the best
thing you've ever made and then she
pulls it out of wherever storage it was
for the past 30 plus years and it's like
remember when you made this like Mom
that's terrible I should bring it home
to her for Christmas oh look at I got
for you Mommy it's really great I don't
know if it would even survive the trip
across the United States to get there
but I'm pretty hyped I think they turned
out pretty great I mean look how look at
this if he didn't know that he was
toppled over maybe he fell through the
ice
foreign
so this is the final outcome of my
crafting session uh wow is really all I
have to say Honestly though from far
away
like this actually looks kind of good
from far away
like look how good it looks it looks
great the further away you get the
better that it looks I'll put links in
the description if you want to check out
the inspiration that these came from and
maybe you could make them yourself if
you do be sure to send it to me on
Twitter I would love to see them and if
you guys haven't already be sure to
check out ijustine.com vlogmas for more
of our vlogmas giveaways it's happening
all week up until December 31st so check
it out I'll see you guys there and also
don't forget to subscribe like this
video If you enjoyed my crafting session
and leave me some comments if there's
anything that you'd like to see me make
in the future I'll see you guys in the
next video bye
foreign
[Music]